[Music]
with an increasing demand for vfx and
cgi virtual production has been steadily
evolving
covet 19 has also accelerated the
adoption of this technology as more
studios move away from traditional
filming
one of the reasons virtual studios
recently received a lot of attention is
because many production companies could
not travel overseas or go on location to
film
hollywood filmmakers including abc and
paramount pictures have already
integrated this technology and sony
built its first virtual production
studio in tokyo so how does this type of
technology work
by integrating virtual background
environments into live action footage
studios reduce the need for onset
production teams and crew members which
of course cuts production costs
[Music]
the virtual production stage is a
production studio where you shoot with a
floating background directly on the led
wall it lets us produce not only movies
and drama series but also extended
reality commercials and all kinds of
other content
a joint report by the british film
institute and arab says shifting to a
virtual production environment can
reduce carbon emissions from transport
which accounts for 51 of an average film
production
globally the virtual production market
was valued at 1.6 billion dollars in
2021 and expected to reach nearly 6.8
billion by 2030 according to grandview
research
north america so far has claimed more
than a third of the market but asia
pacific is expected to grow
south korean entertainment giant cj e m
known for hit k dramas launched its
first virtual production stage in 2022.
[Music]
rvp stage is composed of more than 2 000
micro led panels
we can create any scene whether it's in
the middle of the desert the middle of
the sea or in outer space
it's part of their growing investment in
original content production following
the success of parasite and squid game
our goal is to use the cj e m studio
center where the virtual production
stage is located as a one-stop
production base for all global cake
content
we're still in the very early stages of
virtual production and it's true that
hollywood studios are ahead of us in
terms of technology because they started
first we're working hard to catch up
you